Greetings Sharks, I'm Rener Gracie and I'm seeking a $500,000 investment...
...in exchange for a 5% equity stake in my apparel company, Quikflip.
It was a cold December morning and my son wanted to go to the park...
...so, I threw on my favorite hoodie and off we went.
After about 30 minutes of chasing this guy around the park,...
...the sun began peeking through the clouds and I started to sweat.
At that point, I had no choice but to take off my hoodie.
You can probably guess what my options were.
We have the fanny pack.
We have the European yacht club.
I see you, Robert.
And then we have the wannabe cool guy.
This is the option I stuck with.
But when I finally caught up to little man, I bent over to pick him up.
And the hoodie slipped off my shoulder on to the wet grass.
Oh no!
There has to be a better way!
Sharks, that was it, Quikflip was born.
Check this out.
Flip it, tuck it, shake it, and voila!
In a matter seconds, using our proprietary conversion technology,...
...we can take any outer layer garment into a fully functional backpack in a flash.
With our slide and bite technology,...
...you can adjust the pack to keep it safe and secure during literally any activity,...
...even Jiujitsu with your brother.
But wait, there's more.
You can store anything you want inside the backpack.
And when the temperature drops, simply reach in, take out your stuff with one hand.
Sharks, count one to three.
Too late we're already back to full hoodie functionality in a matter of seconds.
All I need are my black belt business partners...
...to help me submit the outer wear industry...
...and flip your investments into black belt profits.
Who's with me?